Vinnie scale of 10 for you
um kids 10 marriage I'm kind of with gab
where I'm just like bro this there's a
misconception like soul mate you know
people go there's somebody out there for
me the one that's complete it
really is you have to find somebody I
said this for forever that's willing to
put up with your positive and
negative and go on this journey with you
there's not like when people like I know
there's somebody out there no no there's
not you have to find that person and
work together like God put somebody like
you have to go find him like where's
Waldo that's you just gotta be
like it's almost like you have that like
a PowerPoint like are you you're trying
to date okay listen I want this do you
have to negotiate and then be like oh
sorry
that's it see leave slow jams listen bro
she's killing it
but yeah
then you can find the middle ground like
are you down are you down and then yeah
and I kind of agree with like that dude
marriage is a paper contract yeah
one through ten on both
um 10 on 10 both 10. okay I'm a lover
again all right cool all right back to
what we were talking about yeah
yeah this kind of was a segue I'm kind
of in your world one million percent I
want kids I'm gonna be the best dad in
the world
marriage I'll probably have a couple
wives we'll see so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
foreign